professor Carlin the title is education
Zend a two-word title that's packed with
all sorts of possible meanings why don't
we start by telling me what you have in
mind
it's the only pun in the book I maybe I
ought to begin by saying end means two
things
it means the demise of something that
once was an end in the sense of being a
goal or a target or an aspiration in
higher education in the United States
and that was the the the the proposition
that students could and should be given
and organized deliberate even systematic
introduction to the fundamental
questions of life's meaning through a a
guided exploration of the greatest works
of literary and philosophical
imagination that make up the core of our
cultural inheritance that was once
thought of as an educational end in the
sense of goal or or target but that I
deal and the programs of instruction
based upon it have come to an end
they have been terminated for the most
part with a few exceptions here and
there so education Zend plays on that
double sense and is meant to express
those two ideas at once one new start
out in the book one of the things that I
found interesting Lazar made a
distinction between scientific findings
were it's important that you've got it
right as opposed to who finds it out but
then you said nope with the case of the
meaning of life it's the other way
around
good could you elaborate on that well
sure when it comes to the question of
life's meaning the really important
thing is that I come to terms with the
question and find my own way to the best
and most satisfying answer I'm able to
and the fact that someone else my close
friend
even my Roma
or mentor has found his or her way to
that question it doesn't take me off the
hook and it really doesn't satisfy my
own need to find my personal singular
way to satisfy an answer to the question
if I'm studying mathematics or or
chemistry or even the civil war and I'm
wrestling with a question that's at the
heart of that discipline and I open a
book and I see that someone else has
asked and answered that question to
everyone's satisfaction in the field
that's enough for me and I'm happy to
ride on the tailcoats of that person's
inside and discovery but the meaning of
life isn't like that I can't ride on
anyone's tailcoats when it comes to
finding a satisfactory answer or at
least a temporary resting place in my
grappling with that question but surely
if you're dealing with college
sophomores you have to temper that a
little bit because all I'm thinking for
example of Aristotle and so Aristotle
tells us the temperance is one of the
cardinal virtues and as an old guy I
find that pretty reasonable as a college
sophomore I say temperance is a god
that's so this is a meek and mild this
is not what life is all about so how do
certainly at some point there has to be
a certain amount of deference as you're
beginning this exploration into the
ministry we're sure
well I yes and and and a deference is
you know in a way the the the the
compliment to the spirit of Independence
that you want to encourage at the same
time and what what I mean by by that is
this one message that I convey to my
students is look this is a this is a
question that you alone can answer in
that sense you are on your own you are
in the most wildly independent position
with respect to this question that any
human being could be but others
have walked this path before you and
have wrestled with this conundrum and
there is much to be learned from
following their wanderings carefully
thoughtfully with respectful deference
to the enormous energy and intelligence
that they've poured into their efforts
it's true that every human being faces
this question ultimately all alone but
it's also true that we're all in this
business together and there is a lot to
be learned from the hard thinking and
and and and wonderful imaginative
writing that our predecessors have done
so I like to encourage my students to be
at once wildly independent and
profoundly deferential and it's kind of
like stepping on the gas and the brakes
at the same time but it's the right
pedagogical combination all right so I'm
a college sophomore and I say to you
what is the meaning of life I mean come
on I'm going to get on with my life
fine so that's not a question that
really has any relevance to my
day-to-day existence how do you answer
that kind of yeah
well I think I'd say a couple of things
first of all I would be skeptical that
you really and truly believe that and I
might begin by interrogating you a bit
about the informal off-the-record out of
class conversations that you have with
friends and family spiritual advisers
and probing a little bit your claim that
the meaning of life really isn't an
issue or a subject for you at all
and I my guess is that you know at that
at the bottom of it isn't a belief on
your part that this question doesn't
exist that it's not worth spending time
on but the different belief that it's
not a question that can be meaningfully
tackled in the classroom or in an
organized Pro
Grahame of instruction which is a very
different claim or thought or prejudice
I would say and then I think I would
begin to go to work on that and I might
start by superficially suggesting some
of the ways in which a person pursuing
almost any professional activity or or
career needs to have
however specialized their work becomes
needs to have a lateral appreciation of
human beings and the human condition and
of themselves of their values their
aspirations and what they ultimately
care about and that any almost any
important human job on earth requires as
one of its component elements that kind
of deeper background understanding of
the human condition and one's own
humanity as a member of the human as a
member of the human tribe I do think
this is a related point that I make in
the book I think that lots of kids who
arrive on campus to begin their freshman
years thinking that they want to be this
or that an engineer or a lawyer or a
doctor or or an architect and and
believe that they really have to devote
themselves in a very determined way to
the pursuit of that professional the
goal feel that way because they're not
told otherwise by their teachers and and
the presidents and Provost's who run the
shops at which they have arrived for it
for an education
and they get so little guidance by way
of being told even in a gentle and
non-mandatory way you know it wouldn't
be a bad idea if you familiarized
yourself with some of the main works of
Western civilization and then perhaps
with some of the main works and
traditions of one or another of some of
the world's other great civilizations
and we can tell you how to do that they
don't get guidance in most cases even of
that minimal sort and because they don't
they have to find their own way they
have to chart their own course and they
fall back on the idea that preparing for
a career in in a in a very lockstep and
mechanical way is the best use they can
make of this four year period of time in
their life many of them as they come to
the end of those four years and approach
graduation look back over their
shoulders at the time they've spent and
regard it as having been very largely
misspent maybe they've changed their
minds about what they want to be or
doing they go my gosh why did I spent
four years studying engineering ah now I
see that what I want to be as a poet but
more often I think they say you know I'm
well equipped for graduate school the
next phase in my professional career but
I've missed this literally for most kids
once in a lifetime opportunity to take a
deep breath look around and inspect the
human condition let's let's talk about
the an issue you tackle that I think is
going to be one of the toughest namely
the difference between thinking about
the meaning of life as a whole as
opposed to its component parts now if
you are an observant member of a
religion you have a coherent view of the
good end to the meaning of life as a
whole before you if you're secular
it's easy for me to say well I can talk
about family as an important part of my
life and I can talk about vocation but
if I'm secular how do I go about
thinking
life as a whole right that's meaning
right well that's a that's a great
question and you know I worry that the
world we live in is increasingly divided
between the devout who have a holistic
conception of life's meaning as you've
as you've accurately put it and who
comfortably fit themselves into that
conception they know what life is all
about what all of life is all about they
understand where they're going and and
and life as a whole makes sense the
devout on the one hand and the secular
on the other who increasingly regard the
very search for a holistic conception of
this kind as either impossible or
ill-conceived but but in any event not
something that can or perhaps even
should be made a subject of deliberate
investigation and inquiry in a college
or or university in part that's because
the folks on the secular side of this
divide regard question the question of
life's meaning as being tainted with
pietistic prejudices from which they
believe they have happily worked
themselves free and any attempt to put
this question back at the center of
school for them smacks of an unappealing
maybe even ethically disturbing
reintroduction of religiosity into
higher education
I want higher education to be a
spiritually serious enterprise but in a
non dogmatic way by which I mean not
based upon a shared commitment to a
particular teaching
or religious tradition or way of
thinking about man's relationship to the
eternal or the or the divine that's what
I'm after a non-dogmatic non-sectarian
spirituality of a of a serious and
determined the kind but one that leaves
students and and faculty free freer than
they would be within the framework of a
program of instruction that said we
start from certain shared beliefs and
there we go you have as part of that
discussion mmm obviously it used to be
religion and the meaning of life was
everything the knowledge did oh right
you have a wonderful discussion of the
evolution of colleges that I'd like you
to talk about and and especially a long
chapter about the advent of the research
principle in the university and the way
that affected the whole philosophical
underpinnings of what you're supposed to
do when you're in college could you
could you come short you worry about
[ __ ] sure in the first longface longest
by far first long phase of higher
education in America which begins with
the founding of Harvard College in the
1630s and lasts right up to and through
the the civil war the hundreds of
colleges that were founded during this
period that dotted the American
landscape from coast to coast were
nearly all of them religious
institutions based upon initially at
least the premise that education is an
instruction in right living we're right
living means living in accordance with
the dictates of one's religious
tradition and teachings a kind of
Pietism that gave the educational
programs of these antebellum colleges a
solid unquestioned
unscary skeptical religious foundation
Doreen and and and after the Civil War
that way of thinking about the moral
goals of higher education became
increasingly less credible as
skepticisms of one kind or another
seeped into American cultural life and
began to reshape the realm of higher
education at the same time a brand new
unprecedented phenomenon appeared on the
educational scene in the United States
and that was the emergence of the first
American universities these were modeled
on on their German predecessors
it was Americans who had been to Germany
in the 1840s and 50s and 60s and came
back with stars and their eyes who were
they the champions and first creators of
this new system what the new university
system put at it's very center was what
I call in the book the modern research
ideal the idea that an educational
institution is first and foremost a
gathering of scholarly specialists in
various disciplines whose primary task
is to add through their own research and
experimentation a little bit of new
knowledge to the ever-growing pile of
knowledge in their respective fields and
does that idea began to take hold and
teachers in our universities and then
eventually in the whole of higher
education even in our liberal arts
colleges began to think of themselves in
these terms as research scholars the
older idea that a faculty members
primary responsibility is to provide
moral or spiritual instruction guidance
to his students fell by the wayside the
combination of these two things the the
the increasing skepticism dubiety about
old pietistic foundations of the
antebellum regime and the emergence of
the new modern research ideal put that
older tradition of moral spiritual
instruction under a cloud of disrepute
it didn't disappear entirely and in fact
there were many teachers of the
humanities during this period beginning
in 1870 1880 and lasting really until
the middle of the 20th century who saw
themselves as carrying on that older
program of spiritually serious in
obstruction but in a way that was
compatible with the new culture of doubt
and skepticism that had come to infect
higher education and they did this by
continuing to take the question of
life's meaning seriously by putting the
question at the very center of things
but suspending their own authority to
give their students the one right answer
to that question so they would say
instead let us together read some great
books some wonderful poetry and
philosophy examine some lasting the
important works of historical
imagination and reflect on the question
of how a human being can best live the
answer that the answer will be different
in different cases and among these
different answers at the end of the day
they may very well be and in illimitable
conflict which you will have to resolve
yourself on your own wrestling with the
angels in the midnight hour but we are
going to take this question of ultimate
concern of ultimate allegiance and
commitment with utmost seriousness as
our forebears in the antebellum college
did but three of the pietistic
commitments on which their approach was
based
I'm just thinking as you've talked about
that my own experience is an
undergraduate where we approached those
books oftentimes as an exercise of this
is what people said in the past that you
ought to be aware of but they didn't get
to the point of saying and that you want
to see if you can incorporate into your
own worldview it was it was more let us
read the great books because then we
will have read the great books we have
looming ahead of us and this will
probably take a fair amount of the rest
of our conversation the fact that you
are writing against the grain everything
that we know is political correctness
and you have a long chapter on political
correctness makes a lot of the points
you're making difficult to sustain in
that kind of environment but before we
get to the questions of political
correctness I'm curious what kind of
political biography brings a Yale Law
Professor to write this kind of book
well I begin the book with a an
autobiographical chapter recounting my
own experience at Williams College as an
undergraduate in the 1960s a time of
enormous excitement and moral ambition
for undergraduates on American campuses
I was a student activist of the first
order
I left Williams for a year and worked as
a community organizer for SDS which when
I joined it in 1964 was attempting to do
in the North what the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee had done so
magnificently in the south and I wasn't
inspired that's the only word for it by
the moral leadership of these students
and left school and spent a hard year as
a community organizer in Chicago which
among other things caused me to
appreciate the the values of peace and
quiet in a room of one's own and a good
book and three square meals a day and
when I went back to William
the following year I remained active in
student politics I was the chair of our
SDS chapter for the remainder of my time
there then I went to graduate school and
in in philosophy it would not be in
accurate to say that I had burned out on
politics or at least used up temporarily
my my quotient of political passion and
so I retreated to philosophy and spent
the next four years reading Plato and
Aristotle and conte and Heidegger and
musing around and doing this and that
and then went to law school and the law
has I've met many of my colleagues at
Yale would disagree with me sharply I
think on this score but I believe that
the study of law has almost in
electively
a tendency to make one a little more
cautious and conservative in the sense
of being appreciative of the value of
stability the difficulty of creating and
then maintaining institutional fragile
frail institutional arrangements for the
achievement of any important human good
including the good of justice and that
lesson bore in on me with increasing
weight as I studied the law and began to
think of myself more as a lawyer who'd
had a philosophical episode than a
philosopher who had decided to go to law
school and you know about that time I
was introduced to the writings of Edmund
Burke through my constitutional law
professor Alex Bickle who made a rather
dramatic turn in the direction of
classical conservatism late in his
career and that made a very deep
impression on me too and it fit in with
my own deepening sense of the value of
the of the of the civil as
station of learning and writing and
study - which I hadn't at this point
been devoting myself as a student for
more than a decade and that tempered
significantly my liberal political
convictions which have not I would
hasten to add disappeared beneath the
waves I'm a card-carrying member of the
Democratic Party and one of several
co-chairs of the lawyers Committee for
Barack Obama my political sentiments lie
to the left of slightly to the left of
center in the Democratic Party but
educationally pedagogically I would
describe myself without embarrassment as
a conservative I wanted to bring that up
because we're talking about issues that
have have been politically pegged so
that on all the issues involving
political correctness there is a kind of
caricature of the right position and the
caricature of the left position and you
come to this as a good slightly
left-of-center Democrat as you say and
yet you were taking a very classical
approach and and I and I guess I should
alert the readers that particularly
those on the right that as you read this
chapter you are going to see new
perspectives that are not neither left
nor right but they are they are novel
and interesting I'd like to start
quickly on this we have a few minutes
before the break with just talking about
how political correctness affects
pedagogy in the classroom right
political correctness is a phrase that
of course means many things to different
people and it covers a multitude of
virtues or vices depending upon how you
view it but what I mean by it as I use
the term in the book is is an approach
to education which
measures and monitors the selection of
texts and of teaching methods by goals
or objectives which are extrinsic to the
educational program itself which which
measures them by how well they do in
advancing some favored political or
social objective so for example the
proposition that in a literature course
philosophy was a history of course that
texts should be admitted that were
excluded on the basis of how well they
represent the the cause of of fair
representation of justice is between the
races or the the sexes that seems to me
however honorable the political goal to
make that a decisive criterion in the
pedagogical decisions you make about how
to approach a subject what to teach in
it how to teach it that seems to me to
be confusing two very different things
to the harm of the integrity of the
educational process its itself in a
classroom in which there are views about
how one ought to live that students and
faculty feel uncomfortable advancing or
defending because they run against the
grain I'm going to have to ask you to
hold that there and we will be back in a
minute right afterwards and several
other c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts visit book TV Norg
more with Anthony cron Minh and charles
murray
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals over the next few
months in Decatur Georgia
welcome award-winning and best-selling
authors to the Decatur book festival
this Labor Day weekend in st. Augustine
Florida
this September the Florida Heritage
Festival celebrates local authors and
culture the proceeds from the event will
go to the Friends of the libraries of
st. Johns County and the newspapers in
education program in New York you can go
to the third annual Brooklyn Book
Festival presented by borough president
Marty Markowitz just beyond the Capital
Beltway the Baltimore book festival
features kids activities celebrity chef
grilling and authors Ron Suskind Walter
Mosley and Naomi Wolf also that weekend
the National Book Festival is in
Washington DC on the National Mall and
in New Jersey this October the
Collingswood Book Festival offers a
series of workshops panel discussions
and poetry events please let us know
about book fairs and festivals in your
area and we'll add them to our list
email us at book TV at c-span org
afterwards with Anthony cron Minh and
charles Murray continues just before the
break you were talking about some
general terms in which the current and
we will use a word for a phrase
political correctness I know we both
know it's hackneyed doesn't but that's
the word we got that phrase we got to
deal with some some general ways in
which that impinges on the teaching of a
classical education you are engaged in
this in this endeavor you are teaching
the directed studies of course at Yale
which teaches a classical education how
does it feel in the classroom these days
trying to teach this generation of
students yeah well let me give you an
example and men try to make this as
concrete as possible
one of the texts that we read and
directed studies pretty early on in the
fall semester so it's one of the first
books that the the students in encounter
is Aristotle's ethics and the ethics
begins
in its first book with a discussion of
the family and Aristotle among other
things defends the proposition that
there are as as he puts it natural
slaves some human beings who on account
of their own incapacity to direct their
own lives are by nature dependent on
others to do it for them he says of
course there are slaves by convention to
those poor soldiers who were captured in
war and and in slaved because of their
bad luck on the battlefield
but when he's talking about natural
slaves he's talking about something else
and this is a doctrine to put it mildly
buts it's uncomfortably with modern
democratic convictions and the challenge
is in discussing that particular passage
to get the students not to just wave it
aside with the back of their hands or to
dismiss it as a bit of old Athenian
prejudice but to see what Aristotle is
really saying how it connects up to
other aspects of his philosophy even at
the deepest level to his metaphysics and
I often begin that discussion I try to
try to motivate the discussion by saying
well you know what does Aristotle say
about the relation between parents and
children he compares this to the
relation between masters and slaves but
then notes the obvious fact that
children in the normal course outgrow
their condition of natural slavery but
to begin with they are dependent on the
adults around them for direction their
lives have to be shaped from the outside
and we all recognize that and the
students see that it would be fanatical
really to carry their democratic
principles all the way in
the depths of childhood and then the
next thing I say is what about mental
incompetence of a deep and disabling
kind adults who are permanently
childlike in the sense that they're
never able to competently direct don't
we accept that there are such a persons
and most will acknowledge that that's so
some somewhat grudgingly and we'll have
a good discussion about that and once
we've gotten to the one I say so really
there is a there is a category of
natural slaves and the only question is
who is in that who's in that bucket and
perhaps Aristotle put some folks into it
that we wouldn't but we have to find a
way intelligently to square our own
egalitarian convictions with our belief
that there are people permanently
disabled for one reason or another end
in need of guidance from with that and
that's going to make things a little
more complicated for us more interesting
but more complicated I I remember in the
book you also point out that a natural
outcome of political correctness is to
say that the victims are best able to
speak the oppressed are best able to
speak to issues of justice and civil and
you say well but there's also a long
tradition that says the people who are
best able to to see the truth behind
things are the privileged and those who
had education and and a good upbringing
so forth that must get you a few you
know in we have in in our tradition
really two separate traditions with
respect to this exact question who think
who sees things best and most clearly
the well-to-do the healthy the well-off
the privileged or those who are outside
at the margin of things the excluded the
down trodden the victims on the one hand
you have Aristotle in his many dissent
who say the person who sees things most
clearly obviously is the one who isn't
disadvantaged whose life isn't
compromised or maimed in any way who is
whole who's vigorous and vital and whose
human powers have been brought to a a
luminous fulfilling peak and then we
have the Abrahamic tradition the
biblical tradition on the other hand
which from the prophets on has taken
just the opposite view of things the one
who sees it clearly is the person who is
looking at it from the outside and just
because he or she is excluded from power
and privilege is able to see things with
a clarity and moral perceptiveness that
the privileged and well-to-do can't and
the the quarrel between these two
approaches to the question it comes
right down to the present hour and you
will find intelligent vigorous
representatives and defenders of both
views in our culture today and no young
person going to college an heir to this
long and complicated quarrel about
whether insiders or Outsiders have it
right what to be denied either point of
view indeed they should have their noses
rubbed in the irreducible in a liminal
conflict between them this is the
conflict between Athens and Jerusalem
and we have never overcome it mmm I
don't think ever will I think it will
come as news to many students that there
are two views I think that the the
outsider the oppressed views is so
overwhelmingly represented
multiculturalism yes on some things we
can just accept the obvious great
literature and philosophy and art has
been produced outside the West no no
argument at all but we are talking in
this book
mostly about the Western classics and so
you have a wide variety of issues that
you have to do with why choose why
choose this tradition rather than
immerse a student and another tradition
for example right right well for a
couple of reasons but let me preface
what I'm about to say with a cautionary
note which just underscores the obvious
'no subvi espada magic if I were the
dictator of higher education which
thankfully I'm not and thankfully no one
is and could wave a wand and make things
be as I would wish I would perhaps
require certainly strongly encourage all
students to spend a year or so studying
the Western classics and getting their
minds and hearts around the Western
tradition but then I would require them
to spend a comparable period of time
doing the same with the classics of East
Asian civilization maybe maybe Chinese
civilization or or Islam no one who is
about to be a citizen of this global
ecumene that we all inhabit today can
afford to be without the knowledge and
Sensibility sensitivities that comes
with a wider more inclusive appreciation
and understanding of this kind but then
why central emphasis on the traditions
of the West why not say well it's one
very good tradition among several and it
ought to be on the menu for for sure but
there's no reason that it should be
given a preference or priority or
emphasis over any of the others two
things first for most of the young
people who are students in our colleges
and universities today this is their
home civilization and it is vitally
important I believe that they be
acquainted with
and it whatever else they know about and
care about you've got to start from home
but more importantly and more
controversially the global civilization
which is growing up around us as we
speak here this afternoon is a
civilization that is premise in very
deep and important ways on Western
institutions practices beliefs and
ideals globalization is westernization
and though many have tried I know to pry
these two things apart so much of what
globalization means both as a matter of
fact but also normatively cannot be
separated from Western institutions and
Western values modern natural science
the organization of the economies on a
market basis overseeing by regulative
apparatuses of one kind or another
mostly in the form of States the state
it's it's self the the the principle of
toleration as a political ideal
especially as applied to religion the
idea of human rights that every human
being just on account of being such has
certain basic entitlements to respect
and and protection from others these are
all practices and ideas of Western pro
Bono's and the students in our schools
know this in their hearts they recognize
that and the the teacher who stands up
before them in the classroom and
practices a kind of shallow
multiculturalism which purports to
reduce the West to the very same level
as the world's other great civilizations
is preaching a gospel
students in their hearts know to be
false and they may applaud in class and
wave their hands in agreement but when
they walk outside the classroom they
know they inhabit and they want to
inhabit a world that is founded with all
of their the mischief that they have
done which can't be denied founded upon
Western values there is a another theme
that you've got to take up in that
chapter that I had never thought about
it's just fascinating and that is the
nature of the conversation within the
Western tradition as compared to the
other traditions and the ways that
impinges on the whole importance of
studying the Western canon right well
part of being an educated person I
believe is the sense of coming into a
conversation that is already underway
that many others in the past even in the
distant past have contributed to that
you join later on you have to listen
carefully this goes back to what we were
talking about before you have to listen
carefully and with some measure of
deference but not so that you will then
slavishly follow the instructions that
you've received from those who've gone
before but so that you can make a
contribution a fresh contribution an
original contribution may be a poulsen
contribution the shoulders of giants on
the shoulders of giants if you set out
to study all of the great world
civilizations and to take a nibble from
here and a dabble from there of course
on a 19th century Chinese brush painting
and of course on on on Greek political
philosophy and then a course on on on
Muslim theology and you want to put all
of these together in a conversation of
some kind for the most part with
stomachs important exceptions at the
margins
these traditions and the human beings
who have built them have not been in
conversation across civilizational lines
there are exceptions as I say but for
the most part they have not been and
that means if you want to join the
conversation it's one you've got to make
up yourself and believing that you are
in a position to make up your own
civilization from scratch I think is a
recipe for weightlessness and
irresponsibility now I've not in here
because I'm all in favor I live for six
years in Asia I'm all in favor of a deep
study of other traditions but this
superficial take a bit there and a bit
there and think that you have delved
into it drives me nuts I have a
quotation that I'd like to read from the
book because it's a lovely one and I'm
going to ask you to run with it
and you were this is when you were in
the final chapter and you're talking
about spirits in an age of science we
need the humanities to meet the deepest
spiritual longing of our age at the very
heart of our civilization with its vast
powers of control there is an emptiness
that science has created and cannot fill
it is an emptiness that many people feel
and a cause of much anguish and yearning
it is the nursery bed of that great
upwelling of religious feeling of the
surge of fundamentalist belief that is
such a striking feature of life today in
America and the world at large to this
yearning the humanities offer the best
response we have hmm and then you go on
to explain why and I'd like you to do
that from the out well let me say a word
first about the emptiness and the source
of the emptiness we we live in a world
those of us who are lucky enough to be
in the developed world but increasingly
people everywhere live in a world of
unprecedented powers all of the old
barriers are falling away we travel
farther and
faster what we live more comfortably we
live longer than any of our predecessors
in the whole of human history ever have
and the ambition which we all share is
that the future holds more and more of
the same the gold not always expressed
but real toward which this vast
accumulation of powers is striving is a
a god-like independence from our own
mortality and the limits and constraints
it necessarily entails if we could just
be free of that finally we would be
happy but the truth about us is that at
the end of the day what we value in life
would have no value if we were liberated
from our mortality and the dream of our
civilization were finally realized what
would friendship mate or love if we
never died even if we lived for a very
very very long time if we lived for
10,000 years what would a marriage vow
mean what we care most about in life we
care about because it is set in the
matrix of our mortality the world that
we live in dominated as it is by this
driving ambition to assume God's place
through the exercise of immense
technical powers it this world is edits
at it's very core in denial about the
sources and ground of our own humanity
and I believe this is not just an
academic Santa see what I'm saying but
it is a it leads to a sense of emptiness
and quaint lessness in the midst of all
of the
[ __ ] that we enjoy and that that
emptiness and pointlessness is one of
the motive causes of the great upwelling
of fundamentalist religious feeling and
belief that we see of course in this
country but around the world today
teachers of the humanities need to
understand that they have something to
offer in response to this spiritual
longing to and that is the great still
living robust tradition of a humanistic
reflection of poetry and philosophy and
historical reflection on our human
mortality and and the predicament that
it puts us in and if teachers of the
humanities understood that they have
something to contribute to the to the
spiritual needs and yearnings of our age
as as well as the religious leaders
outside the economy who were responding
enthusiastically and him emphatically I
believed that they would they teachers
of the humanities would not only find
their voice again but find a calling for
themselves that would give them
something of lasting importance to do
and to offer to the young people in our
world who are desperately some of them
looking for a way to find some spiritual
meaning in their lives beyond what
science can offer and without the pious
certainties of any religious tradition
yeah it strikes me when we have a
prospect of so much substantially
lengthen the life that nobody seems in
the public discourse to say you know
this could cause a lot of problems yeah
not just demographically but the kind of
problems of the trajectory of human life
that you're talking about
okaythat's it's time to push you a
little bit professor come in Nam well
we'll go onto some of my turf I have
been known in the past for doing some
work about IQ and so let's put aside
whether we can convince the bright non
students of Yale to take these courses I
looked at the appendix that has the list
of readings for the Yale directed
Studies program and I decided just to
look at some of the first and last
sentences of those works and here's the
first sentence of one of the easier
readings John Stuart Mill's on Liberty
the subject of this essay is not the
so-called Liberty of the will so
unfortunately opposed to the miss named
doctrine of philosophical necessity but
civil or social Liberty the nature and
limits of the power of which can be
legitimately exercised by society over
the individual I am NOT going to give
you the last sentence of on Liberty
because it is 126 words long and the
average the average sentence in a
well-regarded comment a high school
textbook in history that I looked at is
13 words and the vocabulary we all know
the stories about how much vocabulary
the average high school student knows
and the rest of it and so my my question
for you is gee this sounds like a good
idea but just how smart do you have to
be to to acquire the kind of education
once per quarter but the real obstacle I
think isn't a lack of intelligence or an
an underdeveloped vocabulary but the
absence of the habits of patient reading
that one needs in order to tackle and
and appreciate even a relatively simpler
although it's a very complex or
relatively a simpler essay like John
Stuart Mill's essay on on Liberty the
kids who arrive in directed studies in
their freshman year at Yale College are
very bright
they're eager they're committed to the
the program but not all of them not many
of them have had a lot of practice in
sitting patiently for
days and days on end and giving
themselves over to someone else's mind
the mind of John Stuart Mill and
following his wanderings thoughtfully
deferentially but of course at every
turn asking themselves well he's just
said that do I really believe that I
want to make a note to come back to that
and reflect a bit more on it but for the
moment I need to follow the this
ariadne's string through the cave
because I need to understand what this
book is about that's not the the the
patience and commitment the the habit of
reading which that requires I think has
relatively little to do with IQ
conventionally understood most of some
of the books we read and directed
studies are notoriously difficult to
consecrate eek of pure reason
I've now batted my head against more
times than I can recall and he's won
every round that's all I'll say I've
constantly defeated by it I feel that
I'm making progress but I'm certainly
not gonna get far in this life that but
most of the book certainly Plato's
Republic this is a difficult and
challenging work but it's entirely
available to the patient reader even
Aristotle's treatises are written with a
common sensical straightforwardness that
makes them open to those who choose to
spend the time we live in an age in
which patience is systematically
discouraged by every at every turn and
by all of our conveniences and
technology I know this myself from my
own experience and to pull the blinds
down so to speak to turn off the the the
all of the machines and to sit with an
old book and allow yourself to become
the critical friend of the person who
wrote it for a week
this is something that you know we're
not so much in the habit of doing much
anymore have you gotten in a lot of
trouble with your colleagues at Yale and
other places for taking this in the end
result view of what education is all
about well you know when I wrote this
book I thought I will have no friends
when it's published because first of all
it is an attack on the modern research
ideal so all of my many friends and
colleagues were committed to scholarship
and and to into research will throw up
their hands and say this is a bit of
romantic and nonsense and why don't you
what are you talking about here my
friends on the Left who are champions of
political correctness in one form or
another would say this is a book of not
not just it's not just a concern for the
book it's a reactionary book and it
would take us backwards in the wrong
direction and then many of my friends on
the right religiously minded friends on
the right would say and some in fact
have said well this is good but it's a
loaf half-baked and we're going to get
back to the kind of spiritually serious
education that the good professor
recommends only when we put God back in
the classroom and it's the pipe
tradition of learning of the antebellum
period that we need to recover and not
what I in my book called secular
humanism well as a person who has
identified with the right I want to
close by putting aside any pretense I've
been able to maintain of neutrality and
say I think this is the most brilliant
book on higher education written in the
last century and to the viewers of any
political persuasion nothing in this
book will cause you to throw the book
across the moat it is it is nonpartisan
it is a rich intellectual feast